[UPBEAT SYNTH MUSIC]
MARK: Oh no, he hit the button.
The button's live.
This is it.
BRIAN: OK, then.
MARK: This is going on air.
BRIAN: We need to do it then.
MARK: Yeah.
BRIAN: Hi.
I'm Brian.
MARK: Hey.
I'm Mark.
BRIAN: And this
is the GCP Podcast
live at Google Cloud Next.
Actually, not live.
MARK: Well, it's kind of live.
BRIAN: The daily rollout of
the Google Cloud Next Podcast.
MARK: We're recording it live,
but it will be edited and then
shipped off.
BRIAN: I think we should move
to interviews right away.
MARK: Well, no, wait.
What episode number is it?
BRIAN: Oh.
Number 1-7-1.
MARK: 171, here we go.
AJA: Hello.
This is Aja, and we're on the
floor at Google Cloud Next.
JON: And I am Jon, and
I am excited to be here
with Andre Kelly.
ANDRE: I'm Andre Kelly.
I'm the product manager
for Stackdriver IRM.
IRM stands for incident
response and management.
AJA: So can you tell us a
little bit more about IRM?
I've heard a lot about it,
and I've heard a lot about it,
actually, internally at Google.
But I don't know
if external folks
have heard much about it yet.
ANDRE: Sure.
So IRM's vision is kind of
to provide fewer, shorter,
and smaller outages.
And the way we try to do
that is through context
and continuous learning--
one, to bring as much
context to the user
during a response, and then
two, capturing that response
information so future outages
of similar types are shorter.
So it's natural,
continuous learning.
JON: How would
developers and anybody
using this be able
to access this?
ANDRE: Sure.
So that's a great question.
Currently, externally
we're available in alpha.
So you can go to
cloud.google.com/instant
response, and you'll see a
page where you can sign up
for the alpha.
AJA: I heard that we're using
this internally at Google.
Is that true?
ANDRE: Yeah.
That's a good point I think
I'll expound on a little bit.
So you should know that
IRM started internally,
and it's really the next
generation Google incident
response set of tools.
It combines a lot of
known best practices
internal to Google, a lot
of previous tools that
were very disparate, that
limited our data analytics
and capabilities
around incidence.
So you combine it
all together in IRM,
learning from those best
practices and new ideas
about data management.
How do we leverage the
ops data to help the user
in the investigation process?
That relates to--
SRE is using it internally,
and our dev on call's
also using it internally.
JON: How can developers
interacting with it--
suppose that there are
any issues that may arise.
How can they submit
feedback with this?
We're always big on getting our
feedback from our developers
and making things greater.
ANDRE: Yes.
Totally agree.
And being the alpha
product, we're
looking for that
external feedback
to make the product better.
So in the app in the
top right-hand corner
and all stacked
over apps, there's
a button to submit feedback.
We also have that mechanism.
And that mechanism
takes a screenshot.
So if there's something
hokey going on in the UI,
it's a great way to
submit that information.
In our docks, there's also
email addresses for contact
us that go straight to the
leadership of the team in terms
of issues you're
having or if something
seems down, for example.
AJA: I know I'm getting
a little bit away
from the specific product,
but can you tell us
some about SRE philosophies and
how you've brought that stuff
into the Stackdriver tools?
ANDRE: Sure.
There's about four of them.
But one of the key ones we hone
in on is make tomorrow better.
It's just an idea of
doing some work today
so tomorrow this kind
of work is easier to do.
So it's a lot of
ways to go with it.
So for IRM, that's the
continuous learning.
Overall, this is also
about reducing toil.
So things that are
very mundane that you
do over and over again, how
can we make it automated
so robots do that?
And that's one of the
key things where we say
we bring the context to you.
So it was very common
in engineers' minds
to go look at the
chart of the metric,
because no one really
believes the alert.
You have to see it for yourself
to affirm that something
is actually wrong.
I don't want to step
away for no reason.
And so we just
bring that to you.
So as soon as you respond, you
see that information and things
that are really related to it.
So that's part of
a way we're making
SRE tenants come to life.
AJA: So you are acknowledging
the fact that we are human
and we have foibles,
and making it
so that the tooling works
with those trends as opposed
to fights against us.
ANDRE: That's exactly right.
AJA: That's awesome.
ANDRE: We have to recognize
humans are humans.
JON: What would you
say is the gem of SRE?
Which practice do you
believe will be the better?
ANDRE: I think the
gem of SRE is actually
one of the harder parts of it.
It's the culture kind
of reflected in SRE.
But one of the key
things in our culture
is a contract, the contract
between business developers
and operators, that we really
believe in this error budget.
And we're going to
believe in SLOs.
And from that,
developers and business
say, OK, so we know
we can push changes
this fast to be
competitive in the market.
And we know that, if in doing
those changes something breaks,
we'll know we'll stop
because reliability
is of the utmost importance.
And that's part of
the op's charter.
Make sure the
application's available.
Make sure that your
users are happy.
But it requires a
triad to really agree
on what that means, what
the guardrails of that kind
of responsibility is.
And I think that's one of
the key things about the SRE
culture that I think is key
to bringing external as well.
AJA: That's awesome.
So we're actually
already out of time.
Is there anything that you
would like the listeners to know
or a place that they
can find out more
about you or about the
tools you're working on?
ANDRE: So IRM is the
tool I'm working on.
As I mentioned, we're
in alpha, and we'll
plan to do a lot
more development.
Looking forward
to feedback there.
So please sign up for the alpha.
Other things I'm
looking forward to
is just kind of how
Stackdriver continues
to provide kind of internal
tooling and skill sets
externally through our tooling.
One of the great examples
of that is Profiler.
It just went GA today.
So we're looking forward to
building up on that foundation.
AJA: That's awesome.
Well, thank you so
much for joining us.
We hope to have you
back in a couple months.
And we can talk at length
about IRM and incident response
and SRE best practices.
ANDRE: That sounds great.
Looking forward to it.
Thank you.
AJA: Hello.
This is Aja, and we are
here in the GCP Podcast
house at Google Next.
And we have another guest.
Would you like to
introduce yourself?
ANNE: Absolutely.
My name is Anne Bertucio,
and I'm on the GCP Trust
and Security Product Team.
AJA: That's amazing.
And our other hosts here?
BRIAN: Brian.
MARK: Mark.
AJA: Cool.
So questions, y'all?
BRIAN: Actually, what does that
mean on the security product
team?
ANNE: You know,
sometimes we feel
like we're a little bit
like the special forces.
I'd like to get us glitter
gold jackets that say "Trust
and Security Product Team."
AJA: That would be amazing.
MARK: Berets?
Could you do berets?
ANNE: Maybe.
Very Frenchy berets.
Like a red--
AJA: I think that would--
ANNE: --gold.
AJA: --ruin people's hair.
ANNE: I'm having even a hard
time with these headphones
and my victory rolls.
MARK: Yeah, I'm sorry.
ANNE: It's OK.
But the Trust and
Security Product Team--
so we really focus on--
everybody has a different area.
I'm container
security, for example.
Some of my colleagues are
identity, threat detection.
But we really focus on how
do we educate our GCP users
about our security
features and help
them understand,
what do things do,
what are they responsible for.
That's a big part
of it, is in GKE
we have a shared responsibility
model helping people understand
here's what you're
responsible for,
here's what GKE security
products do for you.
AJA: I think I
understood all that.
MARK: What are we showcasing
or talking about here at Next
around those topics?
ANNE: Yes.
Oh, about container
security specifically,
we have the GA of binary
authorization coming soon,
which is very exciting.
So binary authorization
is deploy time controls
so that you make sure that
you only deploy container
images that you trust.
So you can decide what
those ATA stations are.
So you know-- I want to make
sure this image got scanned.
I want to make sure that my
QA team took a peek at it.
I want to make sure--
whatever guardrails
your organization needs,
that's going in
your CICD system.
So it's all about that kind of
shifting left mentality rather
than security comes
at the end, security
goes through the whole thing.
And we make sure that you're
deploying what you trust.
That's an exciting one.
We also today, this
morning, announced
the beta for GKE
Sandbox is coming soon.
And that one is-- if you heard
gVisor last year in Copenhagen,
Google opensource gVisor--
container isolation
based on a user space
kernel that filters sys calls.
Well, a little more
complicated than that,
but that's a nice way to put it.
I think the gVisor team
would be cranky with me.
But basically thinking about
how can that user space
kernal handle sys calls so it
doesn't get down to the host,
and we kind reduce
the tax service
for the host kernel
in a container setup.
So we now have a productized
version of that in GKE.
So with one click, you
can get GKE Sandbox.
AJA: Oh, that's super cool.
It sounds like the
Trust and Security
Team is trying to make tooling
so that people can actually
think about this from start
to finish as opposed to just,
oh, right, that security thing,
we should probably do that.
Is that the whole purpose?
ANNE: Yes, that's a big
part of our philosophy
is that we have this phrase
of security by default.
And it's really
that, out of the box,
you should not be able to
get yourself into trouble.
There's always
endless configurations
that endless customization.
But if I just say go, I want
to make Kubernetes dashboards
aren't exposed.
I want to make sure my
credentials are locked down.
Those things should
come out of the box.
MARK: Are there any
sessions happening
around any of these topics?
ANNE: Absolutely.
Let's see if I can
remember them all here.
I think if you go into
hybrid and containers
you'll find quite a
few of them in there.
I know we have GKE Sandbox
on Thursday morning.
Today at 2 o'clock there is
one on workload identity, which
is about keyless entry and
authentication for your GKE
service accounts.
Those are probably my two
recommended ones at this point.
AJA: I think there might also be
a couple on the secure channel
of the livestream.
BRIAN: Excellent.
MARK: Very nice.
AJA: I was looking at
that list this morning.
MARK: But they'll all go
up on YouTube, I assume.
AJA: They will all
go up on YouTube.
And if yesterday was any
indication, most of them
should be up within 48 hours.
BRIAN: So by the time you hear
this, they're probably online.
AJA: At least some
of them will be, yes.
ANNE: If that's
the case, I'll make
a plug for one that
happened yesterday,
which is the "Who
Protects What--
GKE's Shared
Responsibility Model."
I think that's a really
important one for users
to understand here's what
you're responsible for.
Here's what we
take care for you.
AJA: Yep.
I believe that will be going on
a secure playlist later today.
MARK: What's been your favorite
thing on the show floor?
ANNE: I mean, shameless plug
is for the container security
demo.
MARK: Leading question.
That's fine.
ANNE: Yeah.
So in the security showcase,
we have a container security
demo that had been
off looking at,
here's some custom ATA stations.
Let's actually go through
and stop an attack,
stop an untrusted image.
Go back, say oh, there
was a vulnerability
that wasn't cleared by my team.
We're going to go back
and change that out.
So that's in the
security showcase.
BRIAN: Thank you so, so
much for joining us--
ANNE: Yeah.
BRIAN: --and giving us
that awesome overview.
ANNE: Thank you for having me.
BRIAN: Hey, we're here on
day two with Brian, Mark--
MARK: Yep.
BRIAN: --and?
MARIO: Mario.
Hi.
I'm a GDG organizer from Munich,
and we run the cloud community
there.
Yeah, I'm happy to be here.
MARK: Awesome.
Well, welcome to Next.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
What's been a highlight for
you so far here at Next?
MARIO: So basically
two highlights.
The first highlight, of
course, was Anthos yesterday,
but bigger impact
even more is for me
and for a lot of our customers
is MS SQL as a managed
database in Google Cloud.
BRIAN: Neat.
And so I was excited
about that, too,
but why is that interesting
to you and your people?
MARIO: In Germany, a lot of
companies still use MS SQL
and have big MS SQL clusters.
And moving to Cloud is
hard for German companies
due to regulations
of GDPR and privacy.
And big companies
don't trust vendors,
and they want to have
it all their method.
BRIAN: Right.
MARIO: But they start to see
that maintaining infrastructure
is expensive, and
it's hard to do.
And they want to
move to the Cloud.
And when you provide
managed service
like MS SQL, which is your
database that you used
for, like, 10, 15 years, it
makes them way more comfortable
to take the step and
move into the Cloud.
MARK: Fantastic.
Have you seen anything in
particular on the show floor
that you've also thought was
particularly interesting?
MARIO: Yeah, I
talked to the people
from MongoDB and from
Elastic, and it's cool
that Google tries to team up
with the different databases
and search engines and all
of the open source projects
that are basically out there and
try to move it into the Cloud
as well as you don't
need another service
and another service and
another service provider.
You can just have everything
under one company.
BRIAN: All connected closely.
Synergy.
Is there anything
you'd like to make
sure more people knew about your
work or Cloud or other things?
MARIO: Actually, there is.
So we did a lot of study
gems in the last month
to get people
involved into what is
cloud, what is infrastructure.
And when you do a
show of hands, you
have, like, a room of
40 people, 50 people.
And you ask them, yeah
do you use containers?
And you get all of them
showing their hands.
And then you ask something
like, do you use Kubernetes?
And you have, like, three people
in the room showing hands.
And what the industry
thinks is standard
or what many people say
is standard-- like, yeah,
all of the people
use Kubernetes--
it is not the case.
So there are a lot of
companies, especially
that are not so big, like
not of the big players,
but still have a lot
of systems going on.
And they don't know
about the technology
or they are afraid of moving
the technology they have.
Because we did it
for 10 years, and we
will continue the
way how we do it.
And when you show them
things like Kubernetes
or you show them a
service measure of Istio
where they can integrate their
bare metal machines combined
with remote hosted
machines, they love it.
But they don't know about it.
And I think what
is our job to do
as communities or
experts in this field
is approach the people,
show them there are cool
new ways that make
your job easier.
And we provide free trainings,
like the Google community does
with Qwiklabs, to
just teach people
there are cool, new ways.
There are cool,
new technologies,
and they are not hard to learn.
But we just have to go
out and get the people
to do it, because it's
not a thing about, yeah,
it's only working
in Google Cloud,
because everything
is open source.
And you can do it and
use it whenever you want.
And that's what's
really, really cool.
MARK: You mentioned
Qwiklabs, but are there
any other particular resources
that you would recommend
for people who are looking
to level up, so to speak,
on things like that?
MARIO: There's actually a
really, really nice open source
platform for blogging,
which is dev.to,
and it's really
growing community.
And you have lot of people
there that are just starting
getting into technology.
And there are also a lot of
meta-articles for diversity
and getting involved
in tech communities.
And there are a lot
of free resources
where you can find, like, how
do I use Docker in two articles
series and stuff like this.
And I think this
is the resources
that people should check out.
BRIAN: Awesome.
Dev.to.
Thank you very much
for coming and taking
time to chat with us.
MARIO: Yeah, thank
you for inviting me.
MARK: Thank you.
So super happy here at
the Next chair floor
to have Valentin
Deleplace joining us today
to chat about Go stuff.
How you doing, Valentin?
VALENTIN: I'm fine.
Thanks for having
me, Mark and Jon.
JON: Me and Valentin are
very good friends, so--
VALENTIN: Oh yes.
MARK: Excellent.
Then you can just chat,
and I'll sit back.
VALENTIN: Yeah.
MARK: So, Valentin, I believe
you're speaking here at Next?
VALENTIN: Oh, yes, I am.
That's tomorrow.
MARK: So what are
you talking about?
VALENTIN: I'm talking
about performance,
and more specifically,
performance
in Go in the public Cloud,
and more specifically, let's
say, GCP.
JON: Pretty sure the gophers
are going crazy right now.
Can we look forward to possibly
seeing you on livestream
so that our external
viewers can see you?
VALENTIN: Oh yes.
I just got very
confidential information
that's confirmed that
I will be livestreamed.
MARK: Nice.
That's good.
That should mean as well, if
you're listening to this later,
it'll be up on
YouTube pretty fast.
JON: Exactly.
VALENTIN: Oh, good to know.
MARK: Yeah.
So what sort of stuff
are you covering
when you say performance?
That seems like
a very big topic.
What does that mean to you?
VALENTIN: So performance
is making things faster,
especially when things
are a little bit too slow.
And my talk is part high level,
because it's not specific to Go
and it's not specific
to the Cloud.
It's sometimes about
saving cost and handling
more scalability, et cetera.
But that's boring.
What I'm really talking about is
about improving user experience
by making everything
fast, snappy.
That's the main point.
Because we care about
humans, not about machines.
JON: That's great.
And can you give us a
sneak peek as to what
you would consider one of
the more optimal solutions
to making things
faster and quicker?
MARK: Hot tip.
VALENTIN: I'll give
you the answer.
It depends.
[LAUGHTER]
No, so usually the
most important thing
is not to have a lot of
prejudice about what is fast,
what is a good user experience.
You really have to measure
to find the bottleneck,
and oftentimes it's not
where you think it is.
And once you have the
bottleneck, you work on that,
and very often it's possible
or even easy to fix that.
MARK: What are your favorite
tools for tracking performance
metrics or things like that?
Like, how do you observe this?
VALENTIN: So I love
the benchmarking tool
integrated in the Go Tool link.
That's really great.
And then I really, really
love trace and ppov.
It's plenty mainstream.
I mean, many good
developers already use this.
And if you're not sure what
the execution tracer is
or what ppov is, then you should
definitely come to my talk
tomorrow.
MARK: Excellent.
What's been your favorite
announcement so far here
at Next?
VALENTIN: Well, I think we can
say that Cloud Run is huge.
I mean, serverless plus
containers, that is so great.
Thank you, Google.
MARK: Coming back
to your talk, what's
the biggest challenge
you see people facing in
regards to performance, in
regards to their applications?
VALENTIN: Well, that's
a great question.
Usually it's a lack
of observability,
because it's always two parts.
First you measure, and
then you fix things.
And observing what is
slow and what is fast
is not as obvious as it sounds.
So there is tooling.
Sometimes it's well
integrated, and sometimes it's
a little bit more challenging.
And what I witness is as soon
as we've done the first part
of the work-- that is, clear
observability with a nice
waterfall view or
things like that--
then it becomes much more easy
to make the program faster.
JON: Last question
before we let you
go is, who would you say your
talk is mainly geared towards?
I know you said it's more
of an experience talk,
but we'll let our
viewers know exactly
who should follow along.
VALENTIN: Yes, so
the great thing
about Cloud and virtual
machines and serverless,
et cetera, that
Cloud then becomes
more and more decoupled for
the choice of your language.
So most of them, you can
choose any popular language
and it will work.
So some folks are using
more and more public clouds
and are wondering,
should I use Go?
Is it a good idea?
Will my team of developers
use that and like that?
And the key message
that I'm saying
is that Go is really
strong and good choice
for cloud computing.
And I just don't say it.
I also demonstrate it.
JON: Well, that's great.
Well, Valentin, thank you
for joining us, and really,
really looking
forward to your talk.
VALENTIN: Thank you, Jon.
Thank you, Mark.
MARK: Thank you.
Boy, that was a bunch
of great interviews.
BRIAN: Awesome.
MARK: I mean, it's super
cool to see the energy.
It's super cool to
see the people here.
I think we got a
lot of cool people
coming by and just talking to
us about what they like at Next.
BRIAN: It's just the best thing.
Like, all the people
you meet are into Cloud,
doing amazing things with it.
It's fantastic.
MARK: It's super cool.
I can't wait for
the next episode.
BRIAN: Okie doke.
[UPBEAT SYNTH MUSIC]